dang dang dang dang sick dude welcome
everyone back to the general Julian
podcast yeah
I've been sick the last couple of days
Oh Julie what she's taking care of me
she don't really say I did think I
haven't seen you that sick like in years
I haven't gotten that taken years yeah
that was weird and it came out of
literal nowhere I know you went to LA
Fitness and came back crippled that's
actually what happened no I was like
where did you go that I didn't go and
got so sick and it was LA Fitness one
time very weird we went to the gym got
super sick the story of Julian's weekend
um but you took great Kami's thank you
for that uh you're welcome this episode
of the channeling podcast brought to you
by naturebox naturebox delivers tasty
snacks made with simple ingredients
right to your door so you have always
something better to snack on delicious
delicious snacks guys like blueberry
almost quinoa bites and tangy fruit
medley i island pineapple like you could
get me sorry I would go all day
right now you can get two free six by
going to naturebox.com/tyler comm slash
Jenna Julianne also sponsored by texture
guys I know how frustrating it is to
read magazines
anytime I pick up a magazine I feel like
it's already old and it's not for me
texture makes that experience way better
you can read magazines all through the
app that is delivered right to your
phone or tablet basically texture is an
app that gives you an all-access pass to
the world's best magazines right on your
phone or tablet you can browse hundreds
of magazines and cherry-pick the
articles that interest you not the
person who read them before you who are
sitting in your chair before you right
now you can get a free trial i going to
texture calm slash jenna Julie that's
texture calm slash Anjali thank you
sponsor so much better than buying
magazines at the airport that used to be
my old habit
on the plane they upsell you at the
airports who oh my god they're so
expensive they use everywhere I feel
like I wouldn't always buy magazines
like sometimes at the grocery store
sometimes at the airport but like always
if I was getting on a flight before they
were like TV so I was like I'll just go
buy a magazine or two yeah and then I'm
like why did this cost
seventy dollars seventy seventy dollars
literally says John I need those dollars
back anyway anyways we wanted to do this
podcast because people have been asking
our opinion about it and we haven't we
have not rested yeah I mean I talked
about briefly in a vlog but that's not
the same I didn't watch that vlog yet I
usually watch all of your books and I
haven't watched it yet I'm offended um
no basically I was just like so this
happened this is a thing that's happened
and yes it is scary and I base it was
the first day it happened so I took a
screenshot filled a friend goes tweet I
talked about a percent I really didn't
go in-depth it was that well okay so
yeah for those of you that don't know
what we're talking about do have the new
Terms of Service yeah yeah well I have
screenshots so some of it I first found
out about it from Phil defranco's tweet
and video but basically although this
Ian was saying something about they just
made a change to it I don't know
whatever YouTube changed part of their
Terms of Service to include some new
things that are very vague which make it
seem like they could cut off anyone's
ability to monetize under these new
restrictions yeah let me find it sits on
his profile I'm just gonna find a Philly
DS profile but yeah he basically a
couple days ago like almost a week ago
like last week Phil DeFranco got a bunch
of his videos on monetized and it came
out of nowhere they hit him pretty hard
and he was as a lot of people were
pretty confused by it and here is the
new thing that came out is a screenshot
but this is a part of the new against
Terms of Service the update in terms of
service that they released although they
technically have been abiding by this
since 2014 content that is considered
inappropriate for advertising sexually
aggressive content including partial
nudity and sexual humor violence
including display of series injury and
offense related to violent extremism
inappropriate language including
harassment swearing and vulgar language
swearing like that's crazy promotion of
drugs and regulated substances including
selling use of abusive terms such as a
controversial or sensitive subjects
events including substance related or
war political conflicts natural
disasters tragedies even if graphic
images imagery is not shown so yeah so
this basically what happened this came
out I got a lot of people talking
because it was like wait a minute
Phil DeFranco is a news channel and he's
in a way being censored because you know
a lot of people are like it's not
censorship yeah of course it's not
censorship they're not putting a black
bar over his whole video and muting all
of his channel but they're making the
incentive to for him to make any videos
very very decreased if they're going to
demonetised everything he puts up so a
lot of you guys understand you realize
the biggest incentive you know as much
as we may love making videos but a big
incentive to make videos as a youtuber
especially a large one is monetizing
those videos because it lets you eat it
lets you create those videos for next
week and when when YouTube is changing
the Terms of Service or changing their
methods of how they're going about
allowing monetization like kind of at
the snap of a finger it's very scary so
this all went went down last week and we
we needed to get on here and talk about
because we have opinions about him well
I mean some people have come forward and
said that their videos are being like
unmonitored yeah Rob Dyke Phil DeFranco
Rob Dyke who just like seriously strange
he curates you know a bunch of scary
facts and things like that and turns it
into a show but but basically just you
know some gore some CRE zombie horse he
has a series called zombie horse
why would you put that on the Internet
he did mention though one of his videos
I was unmonitored had no graphic content
right um Meghan tonjes made a video
talking about how a couple of her videos
got on monetized that we're talking
about rape or rape culture yeah even
though they were not in the tags it was
maybe just a topic of conversation hjh
we made a video saying like guys the
only thing that you need to do here is
just take it out of the tags take it out
of the title you know take any
controversial words
out of your title and then you can
monetize it so don't say rape don't say
you know different controversial words I
don't know what other specific ones that
we're getting popped for the Proctor Oh
suicide yes kill yourself like those
things but that doesn't fix the problem
that that addresses that like puts a
bandaid on if you're making content on
YouTube and you want to be able to
monetize dance around these topics but
that doesn't like face the larger issue
which is we are now facing the idea
because you know swearing is one thing
and I will say no I personally have not
gotten any of my videos popped or ever
getting on monetized and I will talk
about that in a little bit why I think
that might be but the real issue is
censorship and that we use YouTube as
youtubers as a platform we use as a
community we use as a place of
discussion for a free and open exchange
of thoughts and ideas where people can
be themselves and talk about what they
want and say what they want and reach a
lot of people doing that and by this
system being implemented yeah you can
dance around and make ways so that you
can monetize those videos but the end of
the story is that this is [ __ ]
censorship you know what I mean though
you are deeming which videos in which
content is worthy of being monetized or
advertiser friendly which you know if
you were to look down a telescope of
what that looks like in the future the
people making absolute fluff content and
have nothing to say in them that might
be perceived as controversial like this
entire podcast a lot of people's entire
channels and podcasts we can't say that
and still make money so YouTube would
just be filled with challenge videos and
cat videos and everything that you want
to find might be hard to find or might
not get made at all or set at all
because people don't have endless free
hours and resources and equipment to
make the type of videos that they would
like for free for free
yeah and a okay so an interesting fact
is the this change of search change of
terms so the service for terms whatever
have recently come out you know in forms
of like emails and notifications are on
YouTube dashboard stuff like that so
people are seeing this language that
they've never seen before
advertiser friendly that's language that
people haven't seen before the there is
an interesting thing though supposedly
videos have been being on monetized Rd
monetized right for like two years now
and now it's just when they're notifying
you about it so the scariest part is
like maybe like a year and a half ago I
had a bet bad streak of like three
months where I made bad money and I'm on
I wasn't wondering why that happened
there was no reason why I should have
made that money all my views were the
same
maybe that's why maybe they de monetize
some of your videos and never told you
about it and I think h3h3
did mention this that the problem with
YouTube's communication with its users
like a lot of what they do just doesn't
ever get explained which is so
frustrating and you know as someone
obviously were youtubers but just to see
like for instance when when I saw this
happen I scrambled I like went in my
video manager and I like it took me a
long time because you have to go page by
page on page and search for that little
yellow money symbol Hank green wrote an
awesome article kind of explaining the
whole situation and one of the things he
says YouTube should do is make it so
there's a section in your dashboard now
for d monetized videos so you can easily
find it but it seems as though they've
made that less convenient on purpose
right like they don't want you to see
what's not being monetized it's it's
very weird and I don't know there's a
lot there's and there's like a lot of
how do you want where do you want to go
now okay so I I want this discussion to
be reasons why you think this is because
there's two theories that I can think of
off the top of my head and one is being
heavily discussed and the other one is
not that I can find which is frustrating
me but it's all so [ __ ] controversial
and
I understand that you know if you don't
know me our you haven't watched some of
our other podcasts you know that I am
deep [ __ ] in the rabbit hole
conspiracy theories so this is where my
brain goes to default so I promise you
I'm not a crazy person but that this is
something that I thought about we'll
talk about that second first of all the
one that is being talked about is that
this is YouTube's way of cherry-picking
which content they like in which content
they don't like and which ones they want
to become popular or not so if you look
at YouTube in the past as I'd say
specifically a year you know you have a
you know keemstar you have leafy you
have rice gum you have uh these videos
which you know let me just sidetrack for
one second when that whole like YouTube
is changing thing is going on it really
upset me a little bit and I would just
like to say that these these types of
things have always existed like talking
about youtubers or even talking about
celebrities the demand for that service
has always been there
so these channels in and of themselves
are not the problem you know because as
long as people are willing and want to
watch them they will always exist okay
so I don't think that these people are
terrible people yeah I mean you can
think about what you want about them
personally or whatever but the idea of a
youtuber news channel is not new and
it's people want to see that like
youtuber it's like good you know they're
way far behind guru gossip or robot
gossip the website has been around since
forever and covering Internet yeah and
people want to gossip and talk about
youtubers and what they do in their
personal life somewhat averaged it's not
a new thing um but if you were you know
an executive at YouTube YouTube and you
see all of these channels you know sort
of designed to have a what you can see
is a mean-spirited outlook on the
internet you know rice gum roasting kids
and leafy making fun of kids and there
being an issue with that oh and say you
didn't like that well let's just rewrite
the language in the terms of service so
it makes it so we can cut off their
monetization
in theory control what's popular on our
website and what song because they've
clearly lost control of being able to
deem what people watch and what they
don't watch so for instance if YouTube
saw leaf he you know start his channel
however long ago I don't know how long
ago he started his channel but they
thought to themselves this may not be
the greatest thing to be on our website
but you know we'll figure it out and
then leave he blew up and kind of lot
and then YouTube kind of like lost can
call control as to whether or not people
could watch him or not this does seem
like kind of a last-ditch effort to
throw a blanket on the entire platform
and say okay we might be [ __ ] X amount
of people who are completely innocent
here but we need to do this to to make
it so we can have control again right so
that's that that's one theory that I've
seen floating around that they want to
cherry-pick
which content they like and don't like
and remember we've talked about this up
on the podcast in the past where the
sand pepper thing when people were
flipping out being like here's a
petition we want you to delete his
channel and I stood firm in that podcast
and said this is opening Pandora's box
the second that YouTube decides or has
an opinion about which content they like
and don't like and start cherry-picking
we've you've opened a world of hurt you
know you have to say laissez-faire and
they have for many many many many years
ten [ __ ] years they've stayed as
hands-off as possible and the Terms of
Service are there so that they can say
like okay we don't want porn and like
really awful videos on here yeah and
this is what we mean by that and we will
enforce that rule but that's it
everything else we have to just let be
because we cannot start cherry-picking
content yeah another thing I want to
mention a lot of people have mentioned
like on Twitter and such that in the end
the advertisers are going to deem what
is allowed to be monetized like the
advertisers will have the final say it's
not YouTube's choice this and that and
Wow
that does make sense like on paper
what's been happening for the last ten
years for the last 11 years
like there's
been crazy inappropriate videos being
monetized for like so long what suddenly
changed where advertisers are like oh
now we're changing it like that seems
weird think of Rihanna's VEVO channel
and how many of those videos shown
actual nipples and full ass yeah and in
life there are always going to be
advertisers that are willing to
advertise differently than other
advertisers and that's just the nature
of marketing so for someone to like try
to explain this whole situation by
saying advertisers have spoken you know
this is what they want no because that's
kind of just like one answer trying to
answer ten questions right well that
also boils down to the fact that it
seems like if you were to look at it
this way that YouTube has sided with
dollars they have sided with the
advertisers which is not a good idea
ever because now I no matter what way
you cut it up YouTube I imagined has
this feeling like we created this great
platform for everyone you guys sort of
are indebted to us and you know we pay
you and we do all of this but at the end
of the day when we say jump you say how
high you know they're the end-all be-all
they make the rules and we abide by them
whereas in the YouTube community I feel
it's very much like you know we
appreciate that YouTube made this
platform but we also made it what it is
and I've heard that a million times from
other youtubers you know what I mean
and that you have complaints maybe
sometimes about the way that this
corporation is treating you because you
don't you don't think it's fair and you
would like a little bit different
treatment or you would like things to be
a little bit better because you are the
person that is driving the traffic to
the website do you mean yeah um and now
YouTube has made it very clear with this
statement that they are siding with the
people that are paying for the website
or not instead it we're making people
who are making the website and it's just
not a good idea ever it's not going to
make your creators feel good it's it's
not going to do anything except put
money in your pocket but also like how
does this [ __ ] work yeah how does
this work how are you guys going to make
more money this way if anything you'd
make less money this way and we only
know what we know but it feels like the
amount of communication YouTube has with
its creators even the top creators like
you
so minimal that it begs the question of
I wonder if they have this bad
communication with the advertisers or
with other certain craters are with
other each and they don't lead oh yeah
and I have better communication as it
can't get much worse than the
communication they have with us and I'm
not trying to [ __ ] talk you to because I
have been pretty honest about how I feel
about YouTube and how I feel about
everything but yet you hold on you also
have been very loyal to the platform in
a number of ways for a number of years
absolutely um I didn't hear anything
before this happened probably because I
don't think that YouTube team did
anything worthy of alerting everyone
about you know um but I also was I just
kind of [ __ ] say I just forgot I also
do know in my experience with working
with YouTube is that sometimes it can be
very frustrating even like when Philip
said our Phil DeFranco said that uh you
know his manager are pretty sure
whatever was on the phone with YouTube I
know what those conversations with
YouTube are like it's like they have no
matter who you're speaking with they
have this diction this planned language
that it seems a lot like you're talking
to robots sometimes the way that they
answer your questions they're not they
can pick and say you know I can't really
talk about that or you know I'm not
liberties to say what the answer is to
that I don't know but we'll let you know
you know they're like very nice polite
legal robots in how they deal with your
concerns and that's frustrating it does
a lot of times feel like you're dealing
with an entity that just doesn't
actually really care about you as a
person yeah which sucks but at the same
time you have to understand why they
have to act that way or why they might
act that way yeah but yeah I'm just
going to say it Matthew Santoro had
tweeted out that YouTube is a business
and they're allowed to do whatever they
want in order to help their business and
you would tweeted at him that if that
made you upset because I you know I do
whose livelihoods are on the line here
which is true and and what YouTube is
doing is not right and everyone knows
that so like do I think YouTube is a
business yeah of course but should they
be acting like this no no
should they be dealing with their
creators the way that they have in the
past
no but that
it's well known and everyone knows that
no and now this past on the gray day
under a make YouTube great again that
was the first time that they actually
addressed it because people made a big
enough deal about it it's true and you
know that you brought that up the whole
thing about I said it in a vlog I was
basically like this decision or this
kind of whirlwind of change that's
freaking a lot of people out is causing
sort of sides to be taken amongst
youtubers these the sides are well I
have to really worry now for my content
because all of my content has everything
on this list or maybe some of this stuff
on this list that could very well like
change my future as a youtuber and then
the other half is like well no my
content is clean I have nothing to worry
about YouTube do what you got to do and
I just had a problem with that tweet
that Matthew Santoro tweeted where it
was like guys everything's gonna be fine
no no one worry like this is all good
YouTube's business are taking care of I
thought that was a really convenient
time to tweet that especially because
well a because his content is clearly
clean there's not going to be any sort
of censorship on his content no matter
what and he knows that and also like
it's frustrating that you're you can be
a fair-weather fan sometimes you can be
oh this is us youtubers as a community
all the time and then once you have this
happen you're not going to take YouTube
side and thrown under the bus just
because it's not your problem doesn't
mean it's not a problem that exists
exactly it's really crippling people's
livelihood and rule number one of
[ __ ] life in my opinion is you don't
[ __ ] with other people's money yeah you
know what I mean you do not [ __ ] with
people's money and this is YouTube doing
something and changing how they pay
people and that's [ __ ] with people's
livelihoods and these people have a
right to be angry and upset and want
answers and they have a right to get
answers like you said when the make
YouTube great again
campaign kind of took off and literally
forced YouTube to change stuff that that
was that was the first time that
happened and it was pretty impressive
and kind of wonderful how that went down
I agree well I mean I'm hoping and I've
said this before that YouTube continues
to be its own self policing entity you
know and and YouTube designed the
platform in that way by being so
laissez-faire by having intentionally
vague Terms of Service and I don't think
that this is an exception to that people
are upset with the vague language but
this is how they're able to let people
police themselves as much as possible
you mean by just leaving it open-ended
and then you have people like gray day
and you have you know the whole
community people uprising against this
copyright issue and blah blah blah
so that it when things arise in our
problem we can unite together and create
whatever the [ __ ] would get something
done yeah make change yeah yeah we'll
take a quick second and think this
episode is brought to you by nature box
guys they deliver the tasty wonderful
snacks right to your door with simple
ingredients they have over a hundred
delicious snacks to choose from ranging
from healthy to indulge in all that balm
is but yes they are really good all with
no artificial flavors lots of a lighter
spirit and I was so excited and the
problem is like they send us snacks for
this because we you know we subscribe
and stuff and then even before we have
them for the cogwheel I never leave any
over that's literally how good they're
they have all sorts you guys know how
much I love the strawberry star fruit
ones those are amazing salt and vinegar
veggie chips peanut butter nom noms they
have a whole bunch of surprisingly like
vegan and gluten-free options which is
really really great as you guys know
makes it possible for us to eat them
they have savory they have sweet like
the list goes on and on and I can't tell
you how good these snacks are so go get
yourself some naturebox snacks guys go
to naturebox.com/tyler Julianne you pick
your snacks and you enjoy it's that
simple you literally go on and you
choose what snacks you'd like and it's a
subscription so it'll send it to you
every single month and if you'd like to
change up your subscription you can
change it and they're very great if you
don't like a snack you can send it back
and they will replace it nature box is
good to you check them out nature box
calm
Jenna Jillian get two free snacks also
this week we are sponsored by texture
guys like I was saying before I feel
like magazines are a great concept but
somehow are really outdated and how they
are true so the fact that texture is
able to really cultivate all of the
greatness of magazines and reading
magazines into one app that's really
well-designed
it's a great thing it gives you an
all-access pass to the world's best
magazines right on your phone or tablet
like I said they cherry-pick articles
that interest you so they have an
editorial team at texture that
recommends stories for you based on what
you're reading so you know say you're
reading billboard or Canadian business
or whatever they're going to find in
certain articles that you might like to
read and they're going to put it in the
suggestions tab for you which is really
great because it's you know it's like
someone one of your friends being like
hey check out this article and you know
sometimes you really might like it or
you might find a new magazine that you
never thought you would have read before
yeah yeah
so check out texture guys you can get a
free trial right now and just test it
out for free absolutely free right now
go to texture comm slash annejulien
you'll gain unrestricted access to the
world's best magazines from back issues
to one on newsstands today check it out
thank you to our sponsors awesome
co-sponsors all right well do you want
to transition to theory no it is about
time I think if you can brace yourselves
guys we are bodies all ready for the
other theory okay what's going on so
this theory I have not seen anyone
really talk about this it is my own
theory I'm a cuckoo for cocoa puffs
conspiracy fan and I don't think it's
too far-fetched honestly do you it's not
it's not like the craziest conspiracy
theory you've ever heard it's it is
definitely a conspiracy theory yeah it's
it's not the craziest one of them are
hurt it's still a very conspiracy theory
conspiracy theory spirit EEE yes but um
no it's not it's not absolutely insane
and I think it's worth talking about we
don't absolutely believe this we're not
we're not insane right yeah it's
thinking about please please take this
with a grain of salt this is sort of
like a half conspiracy podcast
okay so this is not us telling us so
years um here we go there we go ready go
okay so I'm just gonna say it the way
that it happened um
Phil DeFranco came out with this and I
of course click on him looking at his
tweet at his video whatever so first
thing that I do naturally is go into my
analytics and I'm like no swearing I my
entire channel is going to be
unmonitored like time to get a new job
BAM you don't I mean like if my channels
on my benefits that's it gas is
definitely in monetized every single
vlog everything is down right because
everyone's like no swearing no talking
about controversial topics no sexual
[ __ ] no nudity no drinking like no drug
abuse like even though I don't do any
drugs in my channel by some stretch of
the imagination all of my drunk videos
are now on monetize right so I'm logging
on to my [ __ ] [ __ ] just prepared for
the worst nothing I see nothing all of
my old videos that have gotten
age-restricted are not monetized or some
of those that have copyright music like
super old nothing within the last
however many years has been on monetized
and I'm like [ __ ] is this [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ] is that so a couple of thoughts
run through my mind right
you know maybe because I'm within some
top percentile of creators maybe they're
giving us more leniency you know maybe
they're not exactly enforcing this
swearing rule depending on what the
content is
maybe they if it's in terms of like
bullying or using it directed at someone
they deem that is excessive swearing you
know I'm just sort of like thinking
about why or what or whatever the [ __ ]
so I sort of go back to Philip
defranco's whole explanation and it sort
of just dawns on me that philip defranco
is reporting the news why is he getting
hit harder than anyone harder than
anyone
why is Rob Dyke why are these people
talking about controversial topics and
mostly news getting and and you can
chime in in the comments and tell me I'm
wrong or you know say that I'm
misinformed because that's totally a
possibility
all this entire theory hinges on what
I'm saying right now which in and of
itself could be wrong but I'm like why
why in 2016 after ten years of YouTube
being so incredibly hands-off about what
people post on YouTube why are they now
just decided that we don't want people
to talk about the news and controversial
topics because if this was about
swearing drinking drugs bullying if they
if it was really about the first theory
that we talked about about
cherry-picking which channels they want
and which ones they don't my channel
would be wiped
PewDiePie like every gamer that swears
would be wiped all the the channels
talking any channel with yeah perceived
as bullying would be white a lot of the
top channels on YouTube would be would
be wiped of monetization the majority of
channels yeah and everyone's just fine
so not to contradict our first theory
but to offer an alternative to the first
theory is that maybe it's not about you
know making these channels that are
popular unpopular or censoring swear
words or really about advertising
there's a possibility that this is about
something other than advertising and
this is about censorship of ideas and
censorship of voices and censorship of
political views like you said
conveniently timed for the right
watching okay okay so that's that's not
really a conspiracy in and of itself but
just hear me out it's more conspiracy
you know it gets weirder yeah it gets
more gluten free okay so why why news
channels why ideas right so forgive me
for not being able to ever say her name
correctly Susan Wood's was Nikki Oh
jakey oh it's as good as well swallow
shudder Susan Susan Shanklin Susan wash
wash nikki yeah aids good okay yeah who
is a lovely woman by the way but I'd
like her very much
remember I did that thing that they'd
come with her and like Susan you look
beautiful today
I do revive
for you she was kind of nervous cuz she
had to give like a doll expedia yep um I
have no personal problem with her I
think she's nice but she has a long
history with being friends with the
Clinton family am I gonna get in trouble
for saying oh there we go here we go I'm
gonna get in trouble it's a conspiracy
there we're removing ourselves from this
we are not saying that this is some
theory we believed in we're offering it
as maybe a thought because we're allowed
to talk about thoughts on the spots I
thought so she has been very good so she
has been friends with the Clinton family
for many many many years this is well
documented I fundraisers that she's
hosted with the Clintons blah blah blah
whatever I would also like to point out
that uh the Clinton administration
however you want to say it people the
Clinton people uh conveniently show up
at places like VidCon um yeah they
actually came up to us at VidCon this
year they sure did I tried to set up a
meeting with you and them through me
okay so side tangent if I if I might I
have made one vlog back during vlogmas
when I vlog the one time um and said
that I've been invited to do these
things that you see youtubers do they go
to the White House they do chummy chomp
politics [ __ ] and I'm just
wholeheartedly against it because I
think that it's [ __ ] up whether or not
you like it celebrities that are you
know doing this whole political thing
sometimes it's nice when they're
informed but for the most part they're
just political puppets used to sway
popular opinion or a people's opinion
that just they don't even they don't
bother making their own opinions they're
like oh my favorite actor likes that
person and they're at that rally so
might as well vote for them you don't I
mean whether or not you want to agree
with that it is the case that people are
swayed by celebrities or youtubers you
know parading around in politics where I
just don't think that it's your place if
you're a if you have a channel if you're
Phil DeFranco or you are someone that's
very outspoken about politics with your
shirt go ahead
like please by all means do whatever you
want but for the rest of us youtubers
that don't really dabble in that
for you to go gallivant around in the
political world it's sort of a little
irresponsible in my opinion or whatever
but I think that it's a little bit it
makes me feel uncomfortable when we go
to these conventions and places and we
see people from the Clinton
administration just sort of walking
around and introducing themselves and
because this is a video convention why
are you guys here yep you know take that
for what it is
CIA is also has someone working with
them my agency that I'm with it they
have someone working with them those
very closely affiliated with the Clinton
administration and you know that that
makes it so that Hillary Clinton can
meet celebrities where the [ __ ] and this
is just me spewing absolute garbage that
I don't really know anything about from
my brain but just to take that for what
it is they the Clinton administration
has some tentacles in some entertainment
places if that makes sense yes which is
I'm trans it's no conspiracy that's well
documented that's out there right people
know that yeah right um so I sat with
the question again you know why in 2016
are we all of a sudden having this thing
where YouTube is unmonitored news videos
so for any of you that know who alex
jones is alex jones runs his own
Infowars
free press complete he was a complete
conspiracy theorist but a lot of those
things have actually been proven to be
like more factual he's not like he's
gone cloud alone yeah and a lot of
people like you I like to listen to him
I like to listen to super conservative
people I like to listen to super liberal
people I like to fill my brain with
other people's opinions and theories
because I think it helps me make my own
yeah um but I have nothing against Alex
Jones but Hillary Clinton just recently
named dropped him in a speech where she
was talking about Alex Jones thinks that
these people that no one died in Sandy
Hook and that these people are crisis
actors in order for her to name-drop
some sort of free press that runs mostly
on the Internet yeah like what the [ __ ]
that's I mean just if you don't know
Alex Jones
maybe just sup and Philip DeFranco fart
it's like Hillary Clinton standing on
podium being like this Philip DeFranco
person thinks blah blah blah and how
dare they like it's sort of jarring to
hear a politician call out the name of
someone running a free press right yeah
you know it's not like she's attacking
fox or CBS or something so the
difference between a free press and
something like Fox is that those giant
news outlets have interests and they're
never there they can also be bought and
sold exactly exactly and that's the
reason why I never but that's that's
everyone knows that you're watching Fox
everyone knows when they watch Fox is
not going to get the break there's
always a bias there's always always a
puppet hand behind closed doors telling
people what to say what to cover which
is well document so that's what Jenna is
saying makes a name drop so crazy is
that she's not saying Oh Fox said this
she's saying a person of Free Press said
this right don't think of it as a
someone said Philip DeFranco not that
Philip DeFranco is is being compared to
alex jones but they are they are the
same in that they are Free Press right
it's yeah it's calling out someone for
their idea and it was jarring to me to
hear that because she's so she's like
slamming someone that she knows she has
no control over no pull over and okay so
stay with me I know that was a lot keep
going okay I'm trying so oh man just
help me help me I'm dropping a guy like
that is gonna inevitably lead people to
go say Oh who's our Jones and they're
gonna go look him up and that might
cause the absolute opposite of what
Hillary Clinton might have wanted yeah
yeah so I thought this was not my quote
but I saw someone had written it that um
Donald Trump is running his entire
campaign on like the internet and memes
and sound bites and vines and whatever
he's running a very new campaign is it's
all against him right even if it's all
bad it's not a traditional campaign yeah
where is Hillary Clinton
running a campaign straight out of 1994
and expecting it to work and now it's
crunch time and she's realizing that
shit's getting [ __ ] and uh she's
trying to address you know free thoughts
because you can't just pay off the news
networks and pay off and expect your
little buddies so whatever anymore you
gotta [ __ ] go for the jugular at
those planes whatever you're doing isn't
working you got to do something more so
this is the theory okay and take it for
what it is and I might get in trouble
for saying it please forgive me it's
just a [ __ ] fairy okay it's crazy
Hillary Clinton is [ __ ] great friends
with Susan Wojcicki
she recently went to a meeting with all
of the higher-ups of Facebook the CEO of
Facebook Twitter I don't [ __ ] know
Susan was their snapchat [ __ ] okay in
Silicon Valley where fancy people mean
about fancy things recently had a
meeting and then several months later
all of a sudden YouTube comes out with
this new policy where they're
unmonitored news channels and
free-thinking so the theory is that even
if it's not Hillary Clinton it's funny
how in September of 2016
you're crippling people's ability to
monetize their news related videos
therefore you know trying to crush or
stifle ideas or free thoughts all the
forces or anything that doesn't align
with your particular political agenda
which is everything because you can't
control who is uploading it right so
imagine I mean this is the only way you
can frame it imagine you're Hillary
Clinton right and you got rich powerful
friends and all across the world in all
different kinds of places and it is
September of 2016 and you know we got an
election a couple months from now mind
you this probably happened a while ago
in order to print to be executed now I'm
gonna go ahead and call in those [ __ ]
favors you know hey Susan Walsh Nikki I
know you have been so hands-off for ten
years what she didn't whatever you know
what I'm saying
hey YouTube I know that you've been
hands-off with your content in 10 years
but people posting and saying whatever
they want is destroying my [ __ ]
campaign right now and people aren't
tuning in to the corrupt news anymore
they're getting their news on the
Internet
I need a way to control what people are
saying and thinking what could you do
online help me help me imagine well it's
just a theory like we said earlier guys
this is this is a conspiracy theory and
it's us just letting our thoughts kind
of take us places especially in a
situation where something as serious as
a channel like Phil DeFranco is being
stifled in a way that it has that screw
you you have to start thinking about why
that's happening you I think that if
they implemented this a [ __ ] channel
like Philip defranco's would get hit
absolutely laughs yeah why is it getting
hit [ __ ] first and in my opinion the
way that this was executed it doesn't
even seem like a secret that they're
trying to take out news and really
disguise it because again like I said
the reason why in the past four six over
long and under the Obama administration
they've been inviting these youtubers
into the White House is because they
have acknowledged that these people have
followings they have their own ideas and
people listen to those ideas their truck
this might be a way to control who is
saying what on the internet how much
when to whom and if they can make money
off of it it's the only way legally
right now that they could maybe control
people's opinions and control ideas
these ideas are very powerful
ya know I like it's uh it's just take
this with like five or six grains of
salt take the whole salt shaker but just
think about it yeah I mean just think
about it I think it's think about it in
terms of that whoever the [ __ ] already
proved that google searches were being
wiped yes in regards to Hillary Clinton
the Twitter hashtags were being
manipulated in regards to lured Clinton
the Facebook was being manipulated in
terms of Hillary Clinton search terms
hashtags all those things were being
mitigated there's been proven this is a
documented stuff yeah so is it too much
of a stretch to imagine now that there
is some sort of manipulation going on
within YouTube about who is making news
and how and what are they saying
and can we cut them off at the knees and
cut off their [ __ ] funding can we
[ __ ] them because philip defranco
will be fine
but he's the exception to that because
most people have not been on YouTube for
a decade of you know gaining sponsors
and creating a policeman right other
forms of income so that you can survive
this might actually [ __ ] some people
who are using the platform is just free
thoughts yeah and and as crazy as this
might sound and as as much as you might
think this is far-fetched or whatever
because which it is
I think it's crazier to not like think
about it you know to me it's like
thinking about all possibilities crazy
or not in a situation like this is kind
of your duty as an Internet person right
now especially if you're making your
living on YouTube you kind of have to
think about every possible situation why
the [ __ ] is philip defranco out of
everyone getting hit why is this
happening why are these people all
across the board not getting touched by
it right why is this answer not being
answered or this question up being
answer why is no one talking about why
are half these people who I thought were
part of this community suddenly backing
up YouTube like what is going on it's
very very strange and even stranger than
a theory that something like that where
it's like okay yeah conspiracy theory
they're trying to pull strings for the
election yeah that's crazy but what's
crazier you know I mean like what what's
crazy what's [ __ ] crazier at this
point
because you know after trying to think
about all the options of what what's
what right now that doesn't sound all
that [ __ ] crazy to be honest you know
I mean I never ever in a million years
imagined like it's always a scenario in
your mind when you're making a lion's
share of your income from one place that
happens to be YouTube or from another
place you're like this is that for me
personally this is not the case for all
youtubers for me personally the majority
my income comes from Google Adsense
which at any moment for any reason could
just be ripped away from you right which
is why like Phil said many people have
created secondary strings are streams of
income leadership stuff like that
anything I don't I've built that there's
a lot of people that have but that's
just it's not the majority no the
majority of people that are make burning
money on YouTube enough to live off of
this is their reality and so you imagine
if this is ripped away from you what
would you do yeah it's hitting where a
lot of people hurt I had a point and I
totally forgot it okay yeah no I I never
imagined in a million years if this day
came where now all of a sudden they're
cutting off people's incomes for one
reason or another I was like you know
who's gonna be here Phillip
[ __ ] defranco he reports the
news what a lovely person completely
like nothing wrong with that whatsoever
never in a million years would I think
that he is the one facing this day
before all of the rest of [ __ ] show [ __ ]
[ __ ] on YouTube yeah [ __ ] show [ __ ] [ __ ]
on YouTube yeah that's a fair statement
like think of all the garbage the hate
the absolute like not even the keemstar
not even the drama [ __ ] or making fun of
other people like the actual like
horrifying stuff that's on YouTube yeah
it's still able to be monetized over
Phillip DeFranco
does that make sense to you no doesn't
make sense me it makes no sense to me
Heidi answers it makes no sense but yeah
I don't get answers I'm just going to
keep letting my brain go where it goes
well okay so long story short when
people were asking us you know what do
you think about this and is it affecting
you or what do you have to say for right
now it's not affecting me it's affecting
my brain my ability to have trust and
faith in the corporation that I'm
working on and for I guess I it it hurts
my heart a little bit to think about
that conspiracy theory or even the first
theory that they are now cherry-picking
content because I think that it's wrong
I think that it's censorship I think any
way that you cut it up it's it's just a
little bit corrupt yeah it doesn't seem
right if anything it just it makes you
feel uneasy and it makes you feel like
you're not safe well yeah any time when
someone's like here speak your mind
upload anything that you want as long as
it's not you know beating someone else
up or just like you're straight [ __ ]
please use this platform however you see
fit and now all of a sudden there's some
clauses to that yeah in order to earn
money
that feels [ __ ] up it does it does
it's very strange I don't I don't know
what else to say it's uh and you know if
in a world where this is some sort of
political monster at work right now
but not saying it is but in a world it
is they're succeeding so well right now
because they're making everyone else
think it's about something else like
youtubers are fighting with each other
it's just what we want this is a giant
distress exactly that that was my
biggest problem is that I tweeted out
that one tweet and then nobody really
like got on board with me nobody really
was saying what I was saying no one
pointed out like this seems like a way
to control news and thoughts and
political ideas no one wanted to go
there everyone's just like oh snap dude
your whole channel is gonna get [ __ ]
deleted I'm like isn't that the most
narcissistic way to think about this
that YouTube really cares that you said
the word [ __ ] in your video and doesn't
want to split ad revenue with you
because of it yeah
and everyone's tweeting about like oh
I'm screwed oh I miss me that me this
they don't care about individuals they
care about impactful and powerful
thoughts and ideas potentially
potentially if you think of it from that
perspective yeah those are the things
that they want to cut off not your
little video where you baked a cake and
you said [ __ ] by accident yeah
so this whole response they're getting
is in this situation inside the response
in and of itself seemed pretty
narcissistic if you ask me
YouTube's in our statistic place what
you think it really did give a [ __ ] that
you just had [ __ ] that one [ __ ]
video from 2000 and [ __ ] 9 no or
every video since you yeah you you
really think that they're gonna go in
there and change the entire terms of
[ __ ] service because you [ __ ] said
[ __ ] one time and there's not an
advertiser the ones that advertise on
the word [ __ ] no not at all
whatever I'm [ __ ] okay
another theory though is that maybe they
are just siding with advertisers and
they just you know people I imagine that
their system for advertisers maybe I'm
making this up an advertiser goes on
YouTube and it's like would you like to
advertise on a video that talks about
rape and you'd be like no thank you
yeah but this is a battle conundrum has
existed for many years trail that's not
new so every to be changing so
drastically is very odd and it doesn't
make sense so we like like we need
answers to know what's going on moms had
deja vu well I mean that's crazy but
like can we be allowed to know the
advertisers that don't want to put their
ads on very close yeah on the news like
that can we know who these companies are
so that we can not buy their products
any that makes too much sense for us to
know that and so that we can make fun of
them on Twitter believe a connection
Julian always says it's a complete joke
don't get offended but Julian it like
he'll see someone on TV that annoys him
who those I want to find his Twitter
account so I can bully yeah I never do
it never that's a joke yeah it's a funny
joke joke anyway guys we'd love to hear
your input please try to
the snow in your in your brain what's
happening what your your idea of what
the answers are and why we're not
getting answers and when we should get
answers I don't know it's it's very it's
a very interesting situation I feel like
when YouTube make youtube great again
that whole campaign that whole Twitter
thing that pushed lasted for what a few
weeks and then answers came so I'm
assuming that can only be the same here
because this this outrage averages seems
bigger mm-hmm as it should be so you
know we felt like we had to address it
so thank you guys for listening to our
thoughts thank you for the discussion
Jenna I don't know yeah yeah it's about
it I mean thank you for sponsors who
support the show thank you your sponsors
who support the wild [ __ ] show Gary I
just threw out there um yeah I mean take
it for what it is and I'd love to know
if you guys think anything differently
because this should be an open and
honest discussion with each other and
with YouTube and yeah I just threw out a
wild [ __ ] political conspiracy theory
but guess what I should be allowed to
say it because that's what this place is
for and I want to keep it that way yeah
so call me crazy but this is the place
for conspiracy theories and if you want
to cut off my ability to conspire you
crazy
as always conspire also shout out to
SoundCloud on iTunes for never censoring
us let's create you true always oh yeah
thanks for tuning in thanks tuning in
we'll see you guys next week I mean I
feel a bundle of weird right now I feel
a little closure
I feel bundle of weird how can we make
you feel better before we close this I
don't know if Ann no hablo just like a
hug okay Lizzy nice hug it up
Oh Thank You Julie oh that's nice hug we
should have just hugged for like two
minutes right never I feel no word I
know last week I had said we have a
guest coming this week and we do have a
guest coming except it will be in next
week's episode the reason we switched
them because we wanted this podcast go
up first cuz I feel like it's more
pertinent but yeah we will have Sarah
from the challenge on next week's
podcast
the future she said out she sewed up we
love you guys bye
[Music]